seit mehr als sechs monaten tobt die
schlacht um mossul die frage ist daher
ist ein ende in sicht
[Musik]
angesichts der heftigen kämpfe muss soll
stellt sich die frage warum diese stadt
zu bedeutend ist einerseits ist sie das
zentrum im norden des irak mit
verbindungsmöglichkeiten alle
nachbarstaaten andererseits einen
islamischen staat hat sie hohe
symbolische bedeutung weil hier das
kalifat ausgerufen wurde und heute ist
es das letzte große rückzugsgebiet und
die bastion schlechthin im irak
militärisch hat sich die lage
folgendermaßen entwickelt im herbst des
letzten jahres gelang es den irakischen
truppen und ihren verbündeten den
ostteil der stadt zu erobern und man ist
nahtlos in den metall übergegangen
allerdings stellt sich hier der kampf
wesentlich schwieriger da warum dafür
gibt es zwei gründe einerseits hatten
die verteidiger zweieinhalb jahre zeit
sich mit sprengfallen heckenschützen
verbindungen und allen möglichen darauf
vorzubereiten
andere setzten die angreifer nicht in
der lage die luftwaffe und auch die
artillerie einzusetzen diese zur
verfügung hätten die aber zu viele
zivile opfer fordern würden und daher
muss darauf verzichtet werden
mittel und langfristig wird es daher zu
erwarten sein dass der kampf weiter geht
allerdings hat der islamische staat ihr
schlechtere karten weil es schon
gelungen ist weiter im westen 50 km
im westen wird die verbindung nach
syrien zu unterbrechen
die angreifer können der waffen munition
gerät in beliebiger zahl nach führen die
verteidiger sind hier total isoliert
heißt das schon dass der islamische
staat verloren hat militärisch wird es
über kurz oder lang wie in den wochen
monaten so weit sein
allerdings werden sich sicher einige
kämpfe in die wüste zurückziehen können
oder schaffen sich auch über die grenze
in andere staaten viel wichtiger wird
aber sein für die zukunft des landes in
mossul wieder jenes element und jedes
politische element zu etablieren
dass solche vielfalt dieser für
integration denn genau das hat gefehlt
und das hat genau zur etablierung und
zum entstehen des islamischen staates
geführt